got tough in this you don't want it
pretty mode on them I was in the
hospital watching the game like this
couldn't watch it for real I was so
scared at the end I went to turn it up
we do these drills in practice it
happens in the game and we go down and
do what we supposed to do that's crazy I
already know who was going to school in
this job when I was watching it was like
bro we got a two-point play and this is
nothing but coach prom situation so I
know we're going to make the best
decision get down get out of bounds get
the ball back to the ref Tempo help us
out a lot because that's what happened
in this moment everything was gone
that's planned man it's God's plan
exactly what he was doing he helped us
all this touchdown Jimmy
98 yards
two minute drill and Coach prompted us
through those situations so much at
forward countless so much during the
week it just come natural to us now that
we already know what's going on we don't
shake up in those pressure moments We
rise in the crushing moments we like the
pressure on us because we get to show
everybody what we're about